This week we'll be
talking about probably one
of the most important aspects
of photography, which is light.
As in photo-graphy
[spoken  phonetically],
writing or drawing with light.
It's a very content-rich
conversation,
we're going to have, and
could really, easily,
take up a full six-week course.
But for our purposes
here, we're going
to give you something
of an overview,
showing you various
forms and characteristics
of some light sources.
We can't address every
conceivable possibility.
But what we can do is tweak
your curiosity, I hope,
so that you pay attention, very
close attention, to what you're
seeing as you change
your own light sources,
looking at the
shadows for example.
How do they and they
and the highlights
change as you move
your light source?
And observe exactly what's
going on when you make even
some very minimal changes.
Let's start with a very simple
piece of equipment, a lightbox.
It's really easy
to use when you're
working with
transparent material,
just by placing
your work directly
on top of the lightbox.
But you'll see
also, later, it can
be also another general
source of lighting.
So let's start with a picture
of these two petri dishes
growing E. coli.
So that works.
In this image, we're seeing
small pieces of colored plastic
shapes, about 3 millimeters
across that are organizing,
or self-assembling
at the interface
between two solutions.
They're becoming a flat
assemblage at that interface.
And all I did was put
the glass container
holding all the material
on the lightbox.
And here, I'm making images
of sugar crystals growing
on sticks.
You know, they serve
you that sometimes
when you order a cup of coffee.
So here is one rendition
on a lightbox of the sugar,
and what I decided to
do for the next one
to simply invert the image,
which we've seen before.
Here's a picture that I
made a number of years ago,
which I still like.
It's a picture about light,
a metaphor about light.
It was one of
those lucky efforts
when I just set up a magnifier
and the paper, [laughs]
and in about 30 seconds,
I got the picture!
(Very unusual, by the
way!) So the image
is intended to suggest a process
of etching with light when
we talked about it in
our book No Small Matter,
about nanoscience.
In this image of something I
assume you recognize by now,
we see a different
kind of lighting
that you've seen from previous
images of the music box.
I shot from above
with mostly daylight,
and then I turned
on a little bit more
light from a
Tungsten lamp above.
This is specific
to this situation,
but you might find
it helpful in yours.
Look what happens when you
just simply click and turn
a light on.
From the light being off,
to the light being on,
you'll see how the
image drastically
changes by just adding
an additional lamp
from above this fishing reel.
Yup [laugh], that's
what it is, by the way,
it is a fishing reel placed in a
translucent, green garbage can.
[laughs] I thought it was fun
to see what kind of quality
I could get by shooting into
a plastic, translucent garbage
can.
Very specific to say the least.
Again, just by adding one
additional light -- this time,
inside the vacuum chamber I'm
imaging ' we see what starts
as this kind of image,
and becomes this image.
You'll see how it really
changes with the simple addition
of just one light.
In this image of a
triangular-shaped water drop --
it's actually an etched area on
a surface onto which we placed
water ' you can see the
reflection of the lamp
on the water drop.
We just directed a
lamp onto the water.
That's considered
direct lighting.
When I shine the
lamp onto a card,
in this case, a gold
card, the light then
bounced back onto the
water drop and you'll
see a completely different
quality of lighting.
This is called bounce lighting.
The bounce gives us
diffuse lighting.
Let's compare the two.
Let's look at a
quick test that I
made for us to see the
difference between two
kinds of bounces.
In this case, the
bounce lighting
will used as fill lighting.
We'll use a white card and
then we'll fill with a mirror.
The main source of light
is daylight from a window.
So, here's an image of
the inside of the watch
that we've seen before,
just with daylight
on an overcast day.
Here, I added a white card
on the side of the watch
for a fill.
Here is a mirror reflecting
the daylight, again, as a fill,
onto the watch.
Let's go back to the original
'just daylight'; then the card;
then the mirror; back
to the watch alone;
then adding a card; then
adding just the mirror.
Let's zoom in to see
the subtle differences
in each of these cases.
Now depending on what
your material is,
you might see much
more dramatic changes.
But I encourage you to
experiment with these ideas.
By the way, here's
another image I
made, this time using both the
card and the mirror as a fill.
Let's see them all together.
Light is all about
shadows as well.
And it is quite remarkable
how small changes can
change the shadow in images.
How a powerful
direct light source
can produce a significant
shadow, and that shadow does,
in this image, become a very
strong compositional element.
Here's where I'm using the
light on this wafer showing
the chip that sits next to it.
In this particular image,
I was playing around;
I decided to just use a slant
of light -- uh, maybe, uh,
Emily Dickenson would
be happy with that.
On this image, I
decided just to make
sure the light was
covering the entire wafer.
I actually like the
first one better,
but it's something
to think about,
about using light in terms
of making compositions.
In this image,
I'm using a shadow
to better communicate what
the grading on the surface
of this plastic is doing.
It's diffracting the light
into different wavelengths.
I produced the shadow
by placing a card
in front of the light source.
See how the image
looks without the card.
Shadows alone can tell a story.
Here, we're trying to show
something called the Marangoni
effect; you know, when you twirl
a glass of wine we see some --
what some people
call 'tears of wine'.
It's a complex phenomenon.
In this image, I
tried for quite a
while to make an image
depicting the Maragoni effect.
Not at all successful.
Finally, thinking that
I should concentrate
on the glass, and the shadow
that is being produced,
then I finally focused in
on what is the Marangoni
effect on its own, as a shadow.
Now, for example, looking at
this small assemblage, which
is about two centimeters across,
I lit this with one light.
It's a monopoint, it's somewhat
of a fiber optic source.
And you could see carefully,
if you look at this image,
where does the light
source come from,
and hopefully you will figure
out that if the shadow is here,
then the light source
has to be around here.
In this next one, I added
a second light source
that not only lights the
device as light to it,
but it also adds another shadow.
And in this next one,
the second light source
has been altered in terms of
its direction and the height
because the shadow that it casts
is slightly longer and even
more so in this
final image where
the light, the
second light source,
is very low compared
to where it was.
And you know that again
because the shadow
is considerably longer.
Now, why bother
looking at all this?
It really is, once
again, learning
to see so that when you play
with your own light sources
with your own
devices, you're going
to pay not only great attention
to lighting of your device,
but the shadows that the
lighting will be producing.
It's important.
It might not seem that way
at this point, but [laughs],
I promise you, it
really is important.